hallöchen freuen und herzlich willkommen
zu einer spontanen aufnahme main war das
ist ein neues pvp modus spielprinzip von
mojang minecraft und es geht in fünf
sekunden los es geht darum es gibt
glaube ich zwei drei vier teams mit
verschnitt haben jetzt endlich drin sehr
laute sound
ich bin jetzt hier drin und man muss
halt erstmal mit rechts die kisten
einsammeln so wie bei wein will man kann
allzu viele items kriegen man haben kann
als wir sind unterschiedliche items drin
man muss halt immer items finden die
gegen solchen kisten sondern auch
einfach hektik braucht dann hat man die
spiel das gerade zum ersten mal so
wirklich hab das noch ein bisschen von e
mail skype erklärt bekommen hierzu
spannende kiste drin
hallo ich glaub ich hab schon alle
sachen die man haben kann brustpanzer
annehme krieg kann noch so wenn ich mir
die sachen antwort dann kriegen die
anderen die auf jeden fall nicht mehr so
gut ich habe erst mal alles items und
wenn man abdrückt sieht man schon in
welchem team an es also ich bin ich bin
ich bin blau das heißt mit razer gaming
leonard 239 dabei indio und ein kevin in
einem team gegen im orangen team neuling
ist annika in zandvoort asylantrags von
julian kraft und im hellblauen team
tobias kentucky der motor die phase
vorbei vom ok den habe ich gut der war
nämlich einem anderen team
und wie schon gesagt es gibt halt viele
verschiedene verschiedene tf 3 viele
verschiedene verschiedene viele
verschiedene teams und jedes team hat
dann ein paar lebensdauer und zb team
gold hat noch 13 leben team diamond hat
noch elf leben und ich bin
wahrscheinlich im team blau das ist team
lapis wir haben noch 13 nebenbei der
fraser gaming rat gestorben ist das
heißt durch 15 leben am anfang jahr 15
neben 120 ich weiß es nicht im gesamten
drehen man muss halt die aus den anderen
team immer töten
denn schaffe ich auf gar keinen fall
jetzt starte ich mich wieder mit einem
gold schwert und muss jetzt irgendwie
mir wieder neue kisten suchen soll die
hier sind in meinem team sei es am
besten laufe ich mit denen rom am besten
ist es wenn man wirklich nebenbei skype
weil man kann sich auch nachher solche
pässe kaufen jetzt hat sie gerade derbe
man kann sie ja nachher in solche pässe
kaufen dass man immer mit dem typen dem
man sich aussucht zusammen in einem team
ist das ist sehr gut für aufnahmen zum
beispiel und ich weiß nicht also habe
ich den verrat abgewehrt das irgendwie
so aus wir gehen jetzt mal auf den hier
drauf und das ist halt zur kuh l'aquila
ein paar sachen sowohl ist so hatte ich
gleich mal sachen ihr seid doch in ihrem
team soll das erschwert da ist ein
schwert in einem bogen haben den bogen
haben so mehr sachen habe ich nicht ja
kein ding schreibt essays treten halt
immer so ein paar teams gegeneinander an
so gibt man die kiste kommen hier einer
von euch von panzer da man muss halt
zusammenhalten das zelt im gegensatz zu
krabbeln main will das sind zwar auch
trader und so weiter alles aber hier
finde ich muss man noch mehr
zusammenhalten man wirklich verschiedene
teams verschiedene einheiten hat jetzt
wirklich eine ganz spontane aufnahmen
wir haben auch nur noch sieben leben
sehe ich gerade für der steward der spec
die diamond ist komplett ausgeschieden
das schon mal schön
wir packen das jugend so schön hier
motivierende worte an an meine
teamkameraden
das sind über den möchte ich nicht so
ganz gerne explodieren sehen eher gut
geht leonard ist auf jeden fall ein
cooler den spieß herum
ich geh jetzt mal einfach ihren mitte da
ist nämlich orangene steam so ich mal
auf denen steht also regungslos rum
sollte er schon mal tot okay da waren
trieb er das auch noch keeper okay ich
bin auch tot
aber unser team love ist hat noch einen
leben niederschriften auf gar keinen
fall dass du die anderen noch zwei leben
wir das schaffen aber nicht jetzt müssen
uns auf jeden fall mal verkämpfen
ok leonard nicht bei mir ja ja ich weiß
wir sind in einem team
cool aber da draußen sind auch andere
von uns das heißt wir sind ausgeschieden
weil fraser gaming gestorben ist so dass
weiter ist mal eine ganz kurze runde von
maine wo ich weiß nicht ob die server
allgemein public sind sonst server ist
der hier also um 1.9 bot com
ich glaube es gibt auch o2 und so was
alles hätte schon verfügbar sind ich
versuche zwei darauf zu kommen
die alpha hat begonnen jetzt al fakih
kaufen
gut 1 kommt man jetzt glaube ich auch
nicht noch mal drauf oder die alte runde
damit ist ein held wieder der lobby ja
genau ins fall dass man jetzt wieder in
der lobby fraser gaming ist darauf hatte
ich sogar darauf der polit man nur wegen
ihnen gestorben sorg kriegen wahlziel
fraser gaming nur wegen diesen wir
gestorben
okay gut freundes was mit meinem ohr
wenn es euch gefallen hat durch eine
positive bewertung da das sind schaffen
wir 1000 likes oder schreibt einer
konnte
4000 likes auf jeden fall hammer ich
habe mich angestrengt hier was
freundlich ist reißen wir hingekriegt
hätte auch eine welle james key er hat
er ja gut ich fand's gut ich ich finde
das geil habe auch aufgenommen so
freunde schreibt mir meine kommentare
könnte einfach drauf connecten ich wette
dann kann ich aber nicht mehr drauf
connecten weil dann alle schon hier
drauf seid und ich das ganze von populis
im populär machen werde
aber es hat auf jeden fall gefallen und
ihr könnt ihr auch einfach mal drauf
kommen und dann würde ich sagen
sehen wir uns beim nächsten mal